et ceci près qu'à bien de sortir même
seringue et se faire un shoot d'héroïne
j'ai attendu ce moment d'effondrement
sociale toute ma vie je ne pensais pas
que ça arriverait comme ça
new york est devenu le théâtre de
dizaines et de dizaines de
manifestations
nous voulons à travers grandes villes un
des quartiers de new york
le taux de criminalité est terriblement
élevé
extrait mieux d'y aller je c'est un art
oui est-ce que je pense qu'on se dirige
vers une seconde vague
je dirais qu'on n'en a pas terminé avec
la première
vous ne pouvez pas filmer ici ce qui se
passe derrière ces murs et n'importe
quoi tom est le pays le plus riche le
plus puissant et oui il à la pire des
réponses
il y à des pays du tiers-monde qui s'en
sortent beaucoup mieux que ça on est
foutu on ne fait rien le nombre de morts
va être si important que les morgues et
on va sans doute les enterrer dans des
parcs mais il est peut-être dans des
charniers
c'est vraiment devenu un sinistre
symbole de la pandémie à new york
[Musique]
voici le mémorial des anciens
combattants du vietnam
il a été construit en mémoire des
américains qui se sont battus et sont
morts durant cette guerre il ya plus de
40 ans leurs noms sont inscrits sur ce
mur de granit en souvenir de cet épisode
dramatique qui a fait 58 morts
américains ces derniers mois le co vie
de 19 a tué environ 150000 personnes aux
états unis
c'est trois fois plus que le nombre de
morts durant la guerre du vietnam en
disant c'est un ennemi différent mais
c'est une guerre et l'amérique
la paire violemment somme quelque chose
ne va pas et nous sommes venus ici pour
comprendre
nous allons examiner comment le
coronavirus s'est engouffrée dans
l'économie et le système de santé
américain est ce que ça implique pour le
reste du monde
allons-y
le new york de 2020 figurera sans doute
dans les livres d'histoire la ville
n'est plus ce qu'elle était les rues du
centre sont désertés ceux qui peuvent
rester confinés chez eux le font et ceux
qui ne le peuvent pas parcourent les
rues masqués comme si le virus était
partout dans l'air
et curieusement tout cela a lieu en même
temps que des manifestations et meetings
sans fin à tous les coins de rue qu'est
le gouvernement aille se faire que le
gouvernement aille se faire trop comment
sortir de ce bordel la révolution et
rien d'autre new york est devenu le
théâtre de dizaines et de dizaines de
manifestations qui se déroulent en même
temps bryce aujourd'hui un samedi j'ai
recensé trente manifestations
différentes liées au mouvement black
live matters et les gens manifestent son
trou pour tant de choses différentes
les inégalités les violences policières
contre le faciès black lives latino
livre france libre tout ce que vous
voulez ces gens par exemple prothèse
contre trump et les agents fédéraux qui
l'envoie dans les villes pour faire face
à la hausse de la criminalité
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça a été quelques mois complètement fou
c'est fou à quel point c'est peu de
temps on était au mois de mars et
soudain voilà on se rend compte que tout
le monde doit travailler de chez soi et
acheter du papier toilette qui est
devenu quelque chose d'une certaine
valeur avril mais on s'y habitue et
blanc georges floyd est tué
plein d'autres injustices policières
contre les gens de couleur sont mises à
jour et ça a explosé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà le coc vide est arrivé il a eu des
pillages
avez vous été dans le centre avez vous
été sur la 57e rue sur la cinquième
avenue sur madison avenue
un million plus d'un million de dollars
c'est incroyable maison de mode
barricadé ferme et disparus et puis les
émeutes d'état d'esprit
j'ai attendu ce moment d'effondrement
sociale toute ma vie je ne pensais pas
que ça arriverait comme cela le pays
tenait grâce à un amphi brillante d'une
colle social qui vient de céder
regardez ça c'est l'un de leurs
principaux slogans
comment on sort de ce bordel la
révolution et rien d'autre la révolution
vraiment je suppose que c'est la
dernière chose qui manquait à ce pays
[Applaudissements]
vous sentez concerné par la
distanciation sociale les gens ne sont
pas deux mètres les uns des autres et
nous crions il nous en avons conscience
est donc l'une des choses
j'ai d'ailleurs acheté des protections
en plus pour les gens et même du gel
hydroalcoolique pour les mains
nous ne voulons pas que qui que ce soit
pour la moindre raison que ce soit soit
un risque pour les autres mais pour le
bien de l'humanité
nous devons être ici verbaliser mais
personne ne conteste l'horreur de la
mort de georges floyd je défie quiconque
de vous expliquer ce qui plaquent
l'animateur il ya tellement de blanc
irisé qui ont leurs signes blacklight
matters devant leur maison ou leur
drapeau lgbt
ils ont tout ça tout ça mais il ne
pourrait vous expliquer comment c'est
comme pour ainsi dire un accessoire
vestimentaire une boutonnière c'est un
style est ce que c'est vraiment ce que
je pense vous vendez les cendriers en
forme de ville mais pourquoi ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok donc toute l'idée de ces cendriers et
de mettre en avant le sexe féminin en
général les gens n'en parlent pas assez
les gens ne savent pas assez de choses
sur ce sujet des cendriers quand vous
pensez avoir tout vu j'ai vu comment
tout cela a commencé
comment les etats-unis se sont ils
retrouvés dans une telle situation
comment on doit se saluer aujourd'hui
avec le cool juste le coude comme ça ok
oui merci
il faut s'habituer à ça il faut s'y
habituer
derrick travaille comme infirmier dans
un des hôpitaux de new york
c'est ça il est aussi était très
critique de la gestion de la pandémie à
new york et dans tout le pays
pensez vous que new york était préparé
pour faire face à cette crise je n'ai
pas l'impression qu'ils ont été préparés
du tout je pense qu'à confinement plus
tôt aurait empêché que ça ne se
diffusent au temps une des raisons pour
lesquelles le virus s'est autant diffusé
que beaucoup de gens vivent dans de
grandes villes comme new york avec un
accès aux soins faible ou inexistant ce
sont les sans abris et les pauvres des
gens qui n'ont pas d'assurance maladie
donc ça va être notre premier lieu de
tournage un petit parc de manhattan où
des bénévoles distribuent de la
nourriture aux sans abri et aux pauvres
les statistiques montrent que le
pourcentage de sans abri qui meurent du
coït 19 et 61 pour cent plus élevé que
pour le reste de la population de new
york
les centres où la plupart d'entre eux
vivent sont connus pour être des foyers
de couronnes à virus
nous allons jeter un oeil et leur parler
pour savoir ce que représente la
pandémie pour j'ai entendu dire qu'ils
donnaient de la nourriture ici tous les
lundis et mardis
on fait dans l'héroïne ici donc rien oui
sans rien
c'est comment ça se passe pandémie pour
vous personnellement comment vous tenez
le coup
pour être honnête je pense que tout ça
c'est des conneries
comment ça commence à me dire des gens
meurent rire des gens meurent
et ce n'est c'est pas ça le truc mais
il ne pensait pas que le comité soit une
vraie menace que ça existe vraiment je
ne pense pas que ça menace qui que ce
soit c'est pas une menace pour moi hop
ça va pas le faire car j'ai des cailloux
du coup c'est pour ça que j'ai du mal
parfois je sais pas je n'arrive pas y
croire
on est foutus on ne fait rien on ne
prend aucune précaution j'ai vu que vous
ne portiez pas de masque
j'en ai plein merci infiniment
ok c'est l'origine de tout mec je sais
juste que je suis dehors et sans abri
ok donc littéralement c'est dingue je ne
rigole pas c'est la première personne
que j'ai interviewés à new york on
arrive à ce titre vient de sortir une
seringue de se faire un shoot d'héroïne
je suis mal à l'aise face à ça c'est un
peu trop pour ces gens ne croient pas
que le coc vide existe ils s'en fichent
vraiment peut-être que la pauvreté n'est
pas la raison principale de la diffusion
du court n 1 virus aux états unis mais
ça de toute évidence contribué aux
mauvaises statistiques pas la new york
il y a particulièrement beaucoup de sans
abri qui n'ont pas accès à l'eau propre
à des antibactériens au gel pour les
mains
même la possibilité de distanciation
sociale relève du luxe pour vous voyez
donc sans cette possibilité
c'est d'abord à trausse pour eux mais ça
induit aussi une possibilité de
diffusion plus large
comment s'est passée cette pandémie pour
comme pour tout le monde
je ne m'attendais vraiment pas à ce que
quelque chose comme ça arrive
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
sorti de nulle part avec coiffeur si par
exemple demain vous sentez des symptômes
ducobu vous faites quoi vous allez à
l'hôpital
vous avez une assurance vous savez quoi
faire
comme ci comme ça j'ai à l'hôpital voir
ce propos faire est ce que vous
connaissez des gens qui ont des abris ou
quelque chose comme ça je suppose que
bellevue serait le premier endroit
bellevue la 26e et la 1re avenue
l'espace est parti de manhattan oui
c'est ça exactement là ok donc ces
hommes nous ont indiqué l'un des plus
grands abri de manhattan il ya eu
beaucoup de rapports selon lesquels ces
infrastructures sont bondés et puis pour
que les gens y ont été abandonnés à leur
sort face au virus sauvette
[Musique]
voilà l'endroit le refuge dont on nous a
parlé il commence à être tard donc les
gens arrivent l'abri pour sans abri de
bellevue a récemment été l'objet de
l'attention des médias quand d'horribles
photos d'hommes dormant sur le sol à
quelques centimètres les uns des autres
ont été diffusées et ce n'est clairement
pas comme ça qu'on peut endiguer la
diffusion du tour aux navires us dans
une ville voilà ce qui s'est passé après
l'indignation publique face aux sans
abri dans le métro ça les autorités de
la ville sont allés les chercher pour
les forcer à aller dans des refuges
le problème c'est que ces
infrastructures se sont rapidement
retrouvés bond et pas assez de lits pas
assez de matériel de protection des
hommes dormant les uns sur les autres
c'est n'importe quoi ce qui se passe
derrière ces murs 3 millions environ 20
centres dans la ville et au plus fort de
la pandémie
ce sont des foyers de comines alfred
crevettes
attendez attendez je peux vous aider non
je voulais juste vous ne pouvez pas
filmer ici
ok d'accord désolé nous n'avons pas le
droit d'entrer sans autorisation et il
ya probablement des gens infectés à
l'heure actuelle nous n'avons pas envie
de prendre de risque mais on va sans
doute pouvoir trouver quelqu'un à qui
parler à l'extérieur
j'ai lu beaucoup de rapports selon
lesquels pendant le pic de la pandémie
il était bondé bondée les gens dormaient
les uns sur les autres c'est ça dans la
même pièce qu'ils étaient supposés être
à deux mètres de distance
mais il y avait 10 personnes par pièce
s'il ya quatre hommes il met quatre
hommes s'étaient l'épidémie la ba na na
de distanciation social en pas de
distanciation sociale que pensez-vous du
coc vite de manière générale tout ce
truc du coc vide je suppose faire
baisser la démographie pourquoi pas
[Musique]
quels sont vos plans pour ce soir mon
plant ce soir c'est d'aller dormir sur
l'herbe
vous avez votre emplacement ouais j'en
ai un par là vous pouvez nous le montrer
ouais bien sûr aucun problème je vous
montre
[Musique]
à le couvrir
c'est comme ça que je n'avais pas peur
amen
ah mais la question ce n'est pas d'avoir
peur c'est d'être sans abri il faut
prendre les choses comme elles sont
ma famille me donne 2 3 dollars de temps
en temps mais ils ne mettent pas
vraiment
[Musique]
c'est une sorte de microcosme de la
crise ducobu 19 à new york dans la
perspective de cet homme s'en fiche
il va dormir dehors ne porte pas de maj
qu'ils ne respectent pas la moindre
distance à sion sociales sauf destin
cet homme a peut-être le coc bide il ne
le sait même pas et s'ils vont les
choses
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
et un paiement lundi à des malades
mentaux dans cette ville là ce ne sont
pas des sans abri enfin oui ils sont
sans abri parce qu'ils sont fous ils
n'ont aussi pas dans pas de chaussures
pas de travail et parfois ils n'ont
aucun espoir
appelez ça comme vous voulez folie
addiction à la drogue à l'alcool ou tous
en même temps je ne sais pas je vois un
niveau de folie dans la rue que je
n'avais jamais vu
allez j'ai l'habitude à j'ai vu des
choses que vous ne pourriez même pas
imaginer
les sans abris et les pauvres ne sont
pas les seules victimes de la crise du
coc vide aux états unis ayez un endroit
pas loin de new york qui dévoile
l'ampleur sans précédent de la
catastrophe
cet endroit s'appelle art island
c'est à environ une heure de new york et
un quart d'heure en bateau depuis le
dock le plus proche
si un corps ne peut être identifié si
une personne n'a pas de proches ou si la
famille ne peut pas payer pour
l'enterrement art thaïlande est la
solution
il a servi de fosses communes pendant
des siècles
mais aujourd'hui avec la pandémie elle
tourne à plein régime
des images aériennes ont montré des
dizaines de corps enterrés dans des
tranchées
[Musique]
oh
selon la rumeur quand ça souffle du
nord-est avec la tempête du nord-est les
rochers du côté font face à l'érosion et
la rumeur raconte que des onze s'échoue
sur city island des choses comme ça ils
suivent le courant et y arrivent les
jours suivants j'ai entendu des gens
dire que des vieux habitants de city
island ont des crânes des trucs comme ça
c'est un peu dérangeant oui
après ça je pense qu'on ne peut pas
s'approcher plus il est interdit de
mettre un pied sur l'île est là dans ce
calme je dois dire que ça donne la chair
de poule c'est la plus grande fosse
commune des états unis combien de corps
sont enterrés là c'est vraiment un
sinistre symbole de la pandémie à new
york
[Musique]
c'est avec ça que nous allons nous
réveiller un matin le nombre de morts va
être aussi important que les morts on va
sans doute les enterrer dans des parcs x
peut-être dans des charniers
nous ne serons pas capables de faire
face à ça il y a à côté des hôpitaux des
camions des semi remorque réfrigérée
pour faire face au nombre de morts c'est
devenu complètement fou
[Musique]
diana enchanté comment ça va
cette infirmière elle a été très
critique de la gestion de la pandémie
dès le premier jour nous entrons dans
une tente de guerre nous ne savons même
pas dans quoi nous entrons nous ne
savons pas qui a ce virus ne savons pas
qui a été en contact ter linden à vous
avez pris part à de nombreuses
manifestations annexes pouvez vous nous
expliquer pourquoi manifester
équipements de protection
il n'y aurait pas dû avoir de décision
quant à qui peut obtenir un masque c'est
inhumain
tout le personnel soignant a le droit à
un masque c'est essentiel il n'arrêtait
pas de dire
n'utilisez pas de masque vous n'en avez
pas besoin on veut pas de gâchis vous
voulez dire que le management de
l'hôpital où vous travaillez vous disais
que vous ne devriez pas avoir de masques
oui disait au début on ne voulant pas
voir des gens porter de masque parce
qu'on veut pas de gâchis n'avions pas
assez de masques passe de blues ça me
semble faux comment se fait-il que vous
m'ayez rien du tout cela donc ce qui est
arrivé c'est qu'on en a toujours eu mais
nous n'avons jamais eu autant de gens en
isolement pour nous retrouver en manque
so we will à à moi normalement nous
avons un ou deux cas nécessitant une
isolation
mais là nous parlons de centaines
nous nous sommes rapidement vous trouvez
en manque et les mains parce que on
n'avait pas anticipé sur la quantité
nécessaire et bien sûr on pense coup je
ne vais pas acheter des centaines et des
centaines de masques sans savoir combien
vont être nécessaires
mais ce n'est pas une question d'argent
n'est ce pas ce qu'ils aient de l'argent
les etats-unis sont toujours le pays le
plus riche de la planète
le pib par habitant est le plus élevé
l'argent est allé aux mauvaises
personnes et au mauvais endroit
les milliardaires ont fait beaucoup
d'argent pendant la pandémie
ils s'inquiétaient du sort des grandes
entreprises donc ils s'inquiétaient des
grandes entreprises
mais il y aura peut-être plus personne
pour y travailler pour les faire marcher
ensuite mais quoi parce que le pdg va
survivre mais ce n'est pas lui qui va
travailler j'ai lu plusieurs articles
dans la presse new-yorkaise selon
lesquelles certaines infirmières ont dû
utiliser des sacs poubelle comme
protection c'est la vérité cela vraiment
écrasa qu'ils ont dû mettre ça parce que
comme je le disais nous n'avions plus
rien les gens tendaient leurs blouses à
la porte bon ok seule la salle
je ne peux pas partir avec mais je vais
revenir et je veux la remettre parce que
je n'aurai pas d'autre c'est masquer ses
blues ses gants ils ne sont pas supposés
être conservés ils ne sont pas supposés
être réutilisés encore et encore vous
n'envoyez pas de soldats au front ça
leur donnait des armes en leur disant à
esi et bonne chance essayez de vous
débrouillez vous pouvez essayer de tuer
votre ennemi et de lui prendre son arme
et ensuite ça devrait aller
la police est équipé pour aller dehors
caser les gens pleins gaz ont de bons
équipements de bon masque masse paiera
ils ont les masques qu'on aurait dû
avoir noué
non personne ne nous a aidés vous savez
c'était notre combat à nous il nous
fallait nous mettre pour tous oui nous
avons demandé à l'hôpital ce qu'ils
avaient à dire face à ces affirmations
mais n'ont malheureusement pas voulu
nous accorder une interview digne de ce
nom
à la place ils nous ont envoyé une
réponse type qui disait je cite
oui nous continuons à remuer ciel et
terre pour assurer à notre personnel
médical un accès aux équipements de
protection ajoutant notre système a
fonctionné à très haute capacité pendant
la plus grande crise humanitaire en un
siècle fin de la citation est le pays le
plus riche le plus puissant et et oui il
à la pire des réponses
il y à des pays du tiers monde qui s'en
sortent beaucoup mieux que ça craint la
chine a fait bien mieux que nous c'est
un piège vous ne pouvez pas expliquer ça
il n'y a aucune excuse si nous avons les
ressources l'argent l'intelligence nous
avons les meilleurs médecins les
scientifiques
tout ça est signe bien et pourtant on
n'y est pas arrivé
nous sommes dit qu'il fallait aller dans
un autre état la floride parce que c'est
devenu un nouveau foyer de coronavirus
aux états unis ces sept derniers jours
73 mille nouveaux cas ont été révélés là
bas c'est plus que dans n'importe quel
autre état
en ce moment il ya plus de 400 mille cas
confirmés en floride
c'est deux fois plus que ce qu'avait qu
new york est presque cinq fois ce que
traverser la chine dans son ensemble
depuis le début de la pandémie
si new york a été l'épicentre du colis
de 19
ce dernier s'est déplacé vers la floride
nous allons y entrer dans un instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va thomas enchanté emma est un
activiste de floride
il sensibilise les gens concernant la
crise du coït 19
il a été au centre de l'attention il ya
quelques semaines quand il a interrompu
une conférence de presse du gouverneur
vous êtes ont te nous avons decca
records tous les jours et vous ne faites
rien vous falsifiez les informations
vous tromper les gens
plus de 400 mille personnes sont mortes
et vous blâmer les manifestants vous
autres n'avait aucun plan
vous ne faites rien honte à vous qu'est
ce qui vous a poussé à faire ça l'état
de floride et un désastre total à
l'heure actuelle nous avons un nombre
record de cas tous les jours
hier nous avons eu un nombre record de
morts
je crois 160 aujourd'hui nous avons 217
et nous avons plus de kaka new york et
qu'en italie qui étaient des épicentres
initiaux de la pandémie et nous sommes
quatre cinq mois après le début et ce
franchement parce que le gouvernement
refuse de faire des choses simples comme
ainsi que le port du masque qu'il refuse
d'écouter des experts retraite
voici quelques éléments concernant la
floride qui montre ce à quoi une
approche hésitante face au co ville peut
mener alors que de grands états comme la
californie et new york se sont dépêchés
de confiner en mars
cet état est resté ouvert bien plus tard
le gouverneur rome de santis a annoncé
avec regret la fermeture des bars
resteront club de sport et autres
endroits publics
en mai le nombre de cas de colis d'aidé
est assez bas en floride
de santis a été parmi les premiers
gouverneur va réouvrir son état il s'est
même vanté d'avoir particulièrement bien
géré la pandémie et sauver l'économie
locale et c'est là que tout a commencé à
se dégrader
les cas se sont multipliés les hôpitaux
commencent à être submergés de patients
des camions réfrigérés sont apparus pour
les corps que les morgues ne pouvait
plus accepter la floride est devenu le
centre l'attention nationale
si vous vous souvenez en fait la floride
a fait la une pendant la pandémie à
cause du scream break
vous savez ces jeunes universitaires qui
viennent dans cette partie du sud de la
floride pour faire la fête en mars parce
qu'ils ont des vacances le comté des
autorités de l'état n'ont rien essayé de
faire pour arrêter ça parce que c'est de
l'argent
c'est ce qu'on voit à l'heure actuelle
disney world s'est ouvert en plein
milieu de la pandémie
donc si vous voulez mon avis c'est
vraiment la visite et le fait que ces
gens veulent faire de l'argent coûte que
coûte fait expliquer au public que nous
gardons nos masques durant cette
interview alors même que nous sommes à
l'extérieur se comptait seulement dans
celui là me hameed elle a été mise en
place
un décret il ya environ deux semaines le
masque est obligatoire sous peine
d'amendé ce décret sur le masque était
passé il ya deux semaines donc
c'est très tard dans la crise je ne
pense pas que dans la floride dans son
ensemble cela a pris autant au sérieux
vous voulez savoir ce que je pense du
port du masque il n'arrête pas le virus
quête vous allez l'attraper avec le
masque ou 100 mais si vous savez je veux
dire vous voyez quand vous portez un
masque votre corps n'est pas en train de
rejeter d'eau salée les particules qui
sont toujours dans votre corps vous ne
respirait pas d'air frais avec le mal
dont vous pouvez toujours attraper le
virus avec le masque j'ai l'impression
qu'on va être plus mal avec le masque
parce que vous respirez votre comment
dirais-je votre mauvaise haleine et vous
aller respirer ça toute la journée
cela va vous rendre malade je pense que
c'est tout simplement de la panique oui
c'est de la panique
la date des élections arrivent donc bon
saut on va voir ce qui se passe en
novembre voyons ce qui arrive en
novembre pas de covilha rien du tout
quelques au vide après novembre
regardez bien tout sera comme avant bah
non j'ai entendu dire que j'attends
toujours que le corps n'a été dans le
test j'ai entendu dire qu'il passait le
corona aux gens en les testant les test
le test du coït 19
les gens vont se faire cost et et ils
reviennent avec le coroner oui c'est ce
que j'ai entendu dire
le contraste est frappant entre la
souciant telle inconscience floride qui
vient d'être frappé par la pandémie et
la tourmente et triste ville de new york
qui essaient de se relever après le coup
dévastateur du coc vide
[Musique]
la crise du coc vide a dévasté beaucoup
d'entreprises aux états unis il ya un
secteur qui a prospéré depuis le début
de la pandémie les maisons funéraires
celle-ci à l'hmr quartier qui a été le
théâtre du plus grand nombre de morts à
new york à travailler sans cesse depuis
le début de la pandémie allons parler
avec son propriétaire pour connaître son
regard sur ces événements
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour comment allez vous bien
je m'appelle constantin enchanté
enchanté monsieur comment allez vous
bien bien la première semaine d'avril
nous étions là un jour et le téléphone a
commencé à sonner
et à chaque fois que ça sonnait et que
nous décrochions c'était pour annoncer
une mort vous aviez déjà vu quelque
chose comme ça
personne dans ce domaine avait vu
quelque chose comme ça et vous savez des
gens me demandent vous pouvez vous
comparer cela aux septembre et jeudi non
le 11 septembre 3000 personnes sont
mortes
on ne peut pas comparer ça en septembre
[Musique]
j'ai vu beaucoup d' images filmées dans
ce quartier où des camions étaient à
l'arrêt devant des maisons funéraires et
des corps étaient placés dans ces
véhicules
c'était fou c'est pour de vrai c'est
pour de vrai c'est ici à brooklyn devant
l'hôpital de brooklyn tout ça c'est vrai
il met les corps dans des semi remorques
restez chez vous c'est pour de vrai
ouais mais mains tremblent parce que
c'est trop dur de regarder ça de voir ce
que je vois en ce moment non il ya eu un
incident malheureux à brooklyn avec la
maison funéraire a conservé les corps
dans un camion et il en a trop stocker
il ne pouvait s'en débarrasser donc les
corps ont commencé à se décomposer
c'était une mauvaise situation pour eux
c'était partout dans les journaux
venez par ici et filmé depuis le fond
[Musique]
à
on va mon dieu c'est cet amour oui c'est
celui qui commença une heure or omar est
en train de finir alexandra arrange le
corps vous savez elle arrange les
cheveux le maquillage quand on arrive
dans un endroit pareil quand la mort est
une question quotidienne
c'est toute une autre histoire vous
savez les gens disent ah je n'y crois
pas vraiment un croyez moi je les ai
vues de mes propres yeux c'est bien la
réalité
[Applaudissements]
avez vous une explication sur l mres qui
a été si durement frappée par le toubib
de 19 comparé à d'autres quartiers de la
ville
la seule chose qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est possiblement comment les gens
vivent les moeurs et d'une grande
diversité une hasard il ya beaucoup de
nationalités très variés prenez une
maison comme celle ci c'est illégal de
films et mais bon ils vont convertir une
cave en appartements font venir du monde
pour aider à payer le loyer ils les font
tous vivre ensemble là dedans c'est tout
à fait frappant aux états unis la
diffusion du coronavirus est directement
liée au niveau de vie d'un quartier
particulier hasard si c'est un quartier
pauvre où se trouvent beaucoup de
migrants dans ce cas le virus va se
diffuser beaucoup plus rapidement et
emportez beaucoup plus de vies que dans
d'autres quartiers
donc si vous êtes dans un quartier plus
prospère vous pouvez voir quelques
personnes sont masse comme s'il n'y
avait pas à s'inquiéter
mais ici à aylmer où la mort est bien
réel et tout proche
il serait difficile de trouver quiconque
sans protection notre société est
profondément inégalitaire comparé aux
sociétés d'europe du nord et de l'ouest
et si l'on parle des ressources
publiques et des institutions des
services il n'y a pas de lire archi ici
donc on est riche si on regarde le pib
et si on considère le fait que nous
n'avons plus de milliardaires que tout
autre pays mais dans un ensemble
incroyablement pauvres en conclusion
c'est un pays incroyablement
inégalitaire ce qui fait que ce genre de
crise va affecter plus certaines
personnes que d'autres anatase adultes
vous pouvez entrer
c'est une partie des cendres qui n'ont
pas été récupérées des cas que nous
avons traité guesde à temps d'un instant
c'est tout cela c'est ce qu'on appelle
les restes c'est ce qui reste après la
crémation d'un corps descendance à
descendre je commence à avoir la chair
de poule
combien
comme je dis aux gens environ 2,5 kg
c'est à peu près ça s'est désolé mais
c'est c'est dingue ce qui reste de ces
ce qui reste de vos wii tm daniel santa
cruz
anthony palerme au hockey c'est et bio
espinosa oui ce sont des noms de famille
et latino 95% de ce que nous traitons ce
sont des minorités et des immigrants de
première génération
hank des gens d'autres pays n'a qu'un
tueur qui sont les plus vulnérables dans
la partie de la société qui a été le
plus touché les mexicains je pense quoi
pourquoi les inégalités dans cette ville
ont-elles automne influent sur la santé
mais parce que d'une part d'un point
pipeau les pauvres ont été forcés de
sortir et oise il fallait choisir être
exposés et gagner s'agit ou ne pas avoir
d'argent pour se nourrir les pauvres au
moins de ressources
donc ils sont probablement plus
vulnérables à tes poils pipeau les
pauvres n'ont pas de choix
ils n'ont pas la possibilité de se dire
je vais rester chez moi je suis sûr que
je les fais laden
alors non je ne sais pas je ne sais plus
tôt vous avez du pain sur la planche
je vous rend votre micro il ya une idée
reçue selon laquelle si tu veux que
quelque chose soit réussie confie la au
secteur privé les etats-unis ont le plus
grand système de soin au monde
c'est un système privés ou semi-privés
disons n'est ce pas donc de ce point de
vue tout devrait bien aller
et bien comme on l'a vu ça n'est pas le
cas il nous suffit d'observer le système
actuel pour voir que ce qui a eu lieu et
mais pas du tout adéquat
il ya des gens submergé par les dettes
médicale à cause du coc vide sans même
compter le reste c'est du chacun pour
soi
les prix sont excessifs il n'y a pas de
limitation de coût maximum je pense que
ça aboutit sur ce à quoi nous devons
faire face aujourd'hui il me semble que
la principale raison pour le citoyen
moyen de faire faillite
ce sont les dettes hospitalière
[Musique]
eyeka salut les gars je m'appelle
jeannette mendes afp j'ai été à
l'hôpital
quasiment un mois avant que nous
commencions cette interview je vais vous
expliquer brièvement l'histoire de
djanet
elle a contracté le qu'ovide elle s'en
est remise
mais ensuite elle a reçu une facture
hospitalière ridicule de 400 mille
dollars et bien miss mendez aujourd'hui
vous rentrez chez vous cool
félicitations merci ma mère m'a dit
qu'en réalité j'ai commencé à recevoir
des coups de téléphone alors que j'étais
toujours à l'hôpital et que cette
facture est arrivée avant que je ne
rentre chez moi vous avez cette facture
oui voilà ce qu'il a été facturé le
gouvernement est supposé avoir aidé et
l'addition est tombé à 75 milles
cod donc ils ont gentiment réduit la
facture mais c'est toujours 75000
dollars
oui mais j'ai commencé à recevoir des
petites factures de différents
départements met enfin à partir du
moment où je suis arrivé à l'hôpital
j'ai eu une facture d urgence une autre
du radiologiste du cardiologue
donc c'est le même hôpital et différents
départements de cet hôpital nous ont
envoyé des factures indépendante
indépendante oui le moment je n'ai pas
vu la facture de l'ambulance je suppose
que s'il faut tout payer ils vont aussi
facturer l'ambulance puisqu'elle m'a
emmené et ramener à la maison
après l'article du new york times
l'hôpital saint luc a bloqué le compte
dix ans or on va revoir combien vous
devez réellement et nous vous enverrons
la facture définitive ce que vous devez
réellement
on estime que ce sera entre 6 et 16 me
c'est ce que je dois payer de ma propre
poche
attendez une seconde vous étiez assuré
au moment où vous êtes arrivé à
l'hôpital non oui j'étais en permanence
assurée donc si vous aviez une assurance
pourquoi payer quoi que ce soit oui
parce que j'ai toujours sybille à payer
qui sortent de la franchise c'est mon
assurance
je suppose que c'est ce qu'on appelle
déductibles déductibles oui oui mais
enfin pourquoi tout cela est-il aussi
peu évident tout cela me semble vraiment
compliqué
non je ne sais pas pourquoi ils rendent
les choses aussi complexe c'est le même
hôpital
ce n'est pas comme si je l'avais quitté
pour aller ailleurs
c'est le même hôpital pourquoi ont-ils
besoin d'envoyer temps de factures il
s'en lave les mains en disant ah mais
j'ai une facture que pour ce département
je ne sais pas ce que facturent les
autres os je vais essayer d'en savoir
plus ils se passent les semaines passent
et rien cela fait combien de temps au
moins trois mois que je suis sorti de
l'hôpital et je ne connais toujours pas
le montant réel le gouvernement
américain a annoncé qu'ils allaient
prendre en charge toutes les factures
quoi qu'il arrive est nouveau mais vous
avez reçu une facture
oui c'est ce qui va surprise aussi c'est
pas clair oui parce que je regardais les
en faut et je me disais elle ne
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer si
je contracte locaux vides ils vont payer
toutes les factures possible j'ai eu
jusqu'au vide rien d'autre mais je me
demande pourquoi j'ai eu des factures
aussi taraf le système hospitalier veut
de l'argent
donc ils vont vous dire bon vous n'avez
pas à payer ça parce que le gouvernement
a déjà payé
ils feront tout pour vous l'arracher
comprenez est le système de santé pour
ce n'est pas fait pour le peuple mais il
n'est pas fait pour que vous soyez en
bonne santé
il n'est pas fait pour vous aider de
quelques manières que ça soit il n'est
clairement pas fait pour vous aider à
payer les factures
c'est un système à but lucratif
que se passe-t-il si par exemple vous ne
payez pas eh bien ils font auprès d'un
collecteur de dette ils feront un
compromis ils feront en sorte que vous
payez quelque chose si je ne paie pas ou
même si j'accepte le compromis cela
reste huit ans dans mon casier
si je veux acheter une maison un toit ou
même louer un appartement cela aura des
conséquences sont mot crédit en gros il
est trop risqué de tomber malade ici
oui c'est ça
vous devez penser être couverts doit
toujours avoir de l'argent de côté pour
aller à l'hôpital
tout cela est un cercle vicieux pour
payer les factures médicales au moins
une partie il faut une assurance pour
avoir une assurance il faut un emploi
mais à cause de la pandémie
le chômage grimpe et atteint déjà des
records
nous voulons à travers brownsville l'un
des quartiers de new york au plus haut
taux de criminalité domicile
[Musique]
les crimes violents se sont multipliés à
travers le pays ces derniers mois
angie en juin à 270 personnes se sont
fait tirer dessus dans les rues de new
york
cent cinquante quatre pour cent de plus
que l'année dernière
tout le monde parle d'humeur que davel
garner un enfant d'un an qui a été tué
par balle lors d'un barbecue et qui
promet si c'est ça désormais un barbecue
same thing quelque chose développe
totalement les vieux résident de new
york se souviennent de l'époque des
années 70 et 80
quand la violence était partout et que
certains quartiers étaient des zones de
l'endroit
nous marchons à travers grandes villes
est-ce que j'ai peur
un peu
excusez moi les gars j'espère qu'on se
promène et on se demandait ce que les
gens que cette zone de new york avait à
dire ça ne vous dérange pas je peux vous
poser quelques questions si c'est ok
pour vous ouais new york c'est devenu
n'importe quoi à cause du coffee de 19
là je danse dans les rues de new york
fait d'illégal je danse depuis que j'ai
16 ans et comment elle allait émettre
calmez vous calmez vous respirez un coup
qu'on a peu m'importe qui font je disais
l'écho vite 19 a totalement fermé new
york et avec le co vide la criminalité a
brusquement augmenté bien sûr et puis
les pillages ou ceux qui n'avaient rien
à voir avec quoi que ce soit les gens
ont juste besoin d'une raison et nerveux
ici c'est juste je cherche une raison
pour faire quelque chose d'idiot
poubelle
j'ai été attaqué on m'a poignardé ils
m'ont ouvert de la halle à wawa j'en ai
tiré des troubles mentaux
vous pouvez pas aller parler à n'importe
qui il faut être prudent qui approché à
qui parler
surtout quand vous voulez dire dans ce
quartier où que ce soit surtout avec les
jeunes vous voulez peut-être parlé avec
un jeune et ils seront là en train de
fumer un truc super que dans xanadu une
autre chose est né serez genre le truc
c'est qu'il faut approcher des hommes y
avoir une conversation avec eux les
hommes vous parleront mais sur ces
bonnes paroles
ok les gars
ce type était plutôt sympa il ne faisait
pas peur du tout ils ont rappelé qu'il
ne fallait pas tomber sur les mauvaises
personnes
on ferait mieux d'y aller
[Musique]
comme le reste du monde les etats unis
se bat contre le coc vide en fin de
compte il fait peu de doute qu'ils
réussiront mais à quel prix
[Musique]
en tout les aspects de la vie à new york
ont été ravagés depuis le cas au coin de
la rue avec son stand de drogue jusqu'au
cabinet d'avocats jusqu'au théâtre
il est très difficile de continuer la
lutte
quand votre camp et en pro à la discorde
et aux troubles et quand ceux qui sont
en première ligne veulent abandonner
adieu je veux arrêter car je ne veux
plus être infirmière alors je ne veux
plus être un membre du personnel
soignant un héros et nous entraîner dans
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas demandé non
nous a pas aidés la lutte à new york est
quasiment terminée mais de nouveaux
foyers sont apparus dans le pays
est-ce que je pense qu'on se dirige vers
une seconde vague
je dirais qu'on n'en a pas terminé avec
la première et cela implique qu'il y
aura bien deux nouvelles victimes
[Musique]